the 2016 Warriors Cavs game might be the
greatest Christmas Day matchup of all
time remember this was the first time
these two teams had played since the
2016 finals when LeBron and the Cavs
came back down 3-1 to beat the Warriors
and bring Cleveland his first ever title
and right after that Kevin Duran signed
with the Warriors in the summer to
assemble one of the greatest super teams
of all time so the hype was real heading
into Christmas and the minute the game
started it felt like a game 7 KD dropped
36 LeBron was lights out from inside and
outside the splash Bros made it rain
from deep Kyrie was crossing over
everyone in sight and we even had
36-year-old Richard Jefferson turn back
the clock with a poster dunk on Clay but
just like game seven in the 2016 finals
it was Kyrie who came up clutch to bury
the Warriors hitting a tough fadeaway
jumper to give the Cavs a 109 to 108
wins and while the Warriors got the last
laugh winning the NBA title later that
year we'll never forget